[Music]
it is always family first for Luke Bryan
his boys Tatum and Thomas were on hand
as dad turned Dodger Stadium into a
country music Mecca it was quite the
weekend for Luke he took the family to
Disneyland Friday and then Saturday he
lived out a lifelong dream playing one
of the most iconic venues in the world
and only we were behind the scenes with
Luke for the entire day yeah that's my
kind of night
since he walked through this place
you've not stopped working I never had
anxiety before show which shop a little
bit with kids back out again don't know
how but Luke actually managed to find
tighter jeans and a shirt
his other concert must have a laugh with
his wife of 11 years Caroline then a
good-luck kiss
Luke's breaking records he's the first
country artist to headline and sellout
Dodger Stadium with his what makes you
country excel tour at home he's raising
his two boys plus his late sisters three
kids how do you balance all this there's
no handbook for you know being married
there's no handbook for being married
and with children and then there's no
handbook to you know to be in a country
singer
I got nieces and my nephews out here
he's just a garbage disposal we just eat
some eats me got him some in and out all
he wanted was in and out and Nobu what
have I done to my children what have you
done in and out Nobu
there's no break for Luke auditions for
American Idol start up again in the fall
and he'll be reunited with Katy and
Lionel but wait
does his bromance with Blake Shelton
have a little competition Katy and I we
would roast each other on TV and we get
back you know we kind of go off camera
we'd be life
what's that cool okay Katy would be like
did I take it too far and I'm like I'm
like you can't you cannot you're friends
with Blake Shelton yeah I mean after
what Blake does to me continuously
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]